scarlet witch has a long history in the
comics
and with one division she's finally
getting her turn on the center stage of
the marvel cinematic universe
but even when she was more of a
background player the mcu has been
dropping easter eggs about her long
history in marvel comics
it can sometimes take a while for marvel
cinematic universe characters to take on
the colorful names of their comic book
counterparts for example
rhodey was only offhandedly referred to
as a
war machine tony stark in iron man 2 and
he didn't officially assume that moniker
until iron man 3.
wanda maximoff on the other hand has
never been called scarlet witch in
any mcu film although she did finally
acquire the name in an episode of one
division
this is chaos magic wanda
but that makes you the scarlet
witch prior to that disney plus program
the closest audiences had gone to seeing
wanda maximoff being called
scarlet witch came during a small piece
of dialogue
in avengers age of ultron in a scene
when tony stark tries to calm hulk down
after he's been enraged by wanda
maximoff's superpowers
stark makes an early nod to wanda's
comic's name
that little witch is messing with your
mind you're stronger than her you're
smarter than her
you're bruce spanner wanda never
referred to herself as
any kind of witch during her subsequent
film appearances but
it seems likely that after one division
she'll own her superhero alter ego
marvel studios chief kevin feige
promised audiences that wandavision
would see the character finally become
scarlet witch wanda was introduced to
the marvel cinematic universe before
disney purchased fox
which meant significant portions of her
comic's backstory needed to be changed
because wanda in the comics was both
supposedly a mutant
and a mainstay on the avengers team both
companies had the rights to use the
character on screen
however both studios were restricted on
what they could do with wanda
as well as her brother pietro maximoff
aka quicksilver
for marvel studios this shared custody
agreement meant that they could use
wanda but
couldn't make her a mutant or obviously
the daughter of magneto
thus while wanda still has a twin
brother named pietro maximoff in the mcu
her parents are normal human beings
another part of her origin story that
was altered
the mcu's version of wanda hails from
the european country of sokovia
rather than her original comic book
country of origin transia
though the names of the countries have
changed sokovia bears more than a
passing resemblance to wanda's original
homeland
like transient sokovia is a fictional
eastern european country
rife with political turmoil making it a
subtle nod to wanda maximoff's original
home for comics fans
not all superheroes start out as
superheroes
some start out like tony stark arrogance
people so blinded by their own wealth
that they can't see how their actions
affect others
other superheroes begin their journeys
as outright super villains
like wanda maximoff she and her brother
pietro began their time in the marvel
cinematic universe as
voluntary human guinea pigs for the
terrorist organization known as hydra
these experiments gave them both their
superpowers and
they eventually joined forces with the
diabolical robot ultron
as his super-powered henchmen in their
time working for ultron
wanda and her brother tormented the
avengers and helped lay the groundwork
for the maniacal robot's plan for world
domination while this
is different from the duo's origin story
in the comics
it isn't a complete change wanda also
started out as a villain there as well
there she and pietro as the children of
magneto were
critical figures in the brotherhood of
mutants and frequently fought the x-men
much like their film incarnations though
wanda and pietro didn't stay villainous
for long
how could you how could i what you said
we would destroy the avengers make a
better world
it will be better in both mediums they
eventually turned against their evil
masters
and went on to work for the avengers
just as
comics readers always suspected they
would the
suburban new jersey setting of one
division is a gift that keeps on giving
on the surface it allows the show to pay
homage to classic sitcoms
many of which also take place in the
suburbs it works for the show but
it wasn't just invented for tv this
superhero duo's new jersey roots
actually go all the way back to an
offbeat storyline in the 1985 comic
series the vision and the scarlet witch
in that series the couple moves to the
new jersey suburbs after getting married
to enjoy a life together
unfortunately it isn't that easy the
locals aren't happy with a human android
marriage happening in their community
the source of conflict in the vision in
scarlet witch is
more mundane than the supernatural
goings-on that fuel the plot of one
division
but putting the pair in west view adds a
connective tissue to wanda and vision's
prior comic book series
as well as 2016's vision series which
saw the character of vision once again
retreating to the suburbs with the new
synthezoid family
in the mcu hawkeye and wanda maximoff
have developed a close bond
since meeting an avengers age of ultron
their first big meeting didn't seem to
signal that dynamic though as it
entailed wanda still working as a minion
of ultron
trying to sneak up on hawkeye only for
the archer to plug an electric
arrow onto her forehead however the two
superheroes grew closer once wanda
defected to the avengers
this was solidified by the climax of age
of ultron
which saw hawkeye giving wanda a big
speech about what it means to be an
avenger
okay look the city is flying we're
fighting an army of robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense
his rapport with wanda took on a
paternal sense of protection after her
brother pietro sacrificed himself to
save hawkeye
just like that she had lost the only
family she had left in the world
so hawkeye stepped in to help her feel
like she still had somewhere she
belonged
the pair has also had a close bond in
the comics though
it's been more complicated there instead
of having paternal feelings for wanda in
the comics
hawkeye sees her more as a romantic
interest
at least until vision shows up in her
life while their relationship has been
altered for the movies
hawkeye and wanda's closeness in the mcu
echoes the comics that came before it
though one division marks the first time
wanda maximoff has used her superpowers
to create a persistent alternate reality
in the marvel cinematic universe it's
something she's accomplished in the
comics before
more than once her abilities in this
department were most famously the crux
of the comic book story line house event
which was penned by brian michael bendis
in 2005.
here wanda much like in one division is
in a period of deep emotional distress
though in house of m her grief is the
result of losing her children
not losing vision to cope with her
crushing
sadness wanda decides to escape by
creating her own
alternate reality this decision doesn't
just impact wanda though
it sends the entire marvel universe into
chaos creating a world
run by mutants under the cold rule of
the family of magneto
when the rest of the heroes in the
marvel universe wake up to what's going
on
they're forced to come together to stop
wanda at any cost and set the world
right again looking at house of m's
broad strokes it's clear
wand division takes cues from this
comic's event including the emphasis on
wanda navigating very
real emotional problems through her
superpowers
there are clear and major differences
between the comics and the show but the
similarities between the two
are impossible to miss check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]